hello welcome to this video playing em
western wow that guy has really brought
his rating up and usually if we play a
slight favorite away or will i equal
terms but to 480 that's high hmm c5 I
don't know the theory here to be honest
and let's just develop stuff just try to
be quick about it if not doing something
fancy md5 not before maybe okay should
be the end of the world
let go back okay once you go 97 95 here
preventing that for the moment
ok
I don't really believe that this is bad
for me it takes takes rook c7 should be
active enough
yeah I wanted to play this this a bit
quicker this game not trying to do
something great just just just be quick
about it okay so 27
teka droop chicks okay five rupee true
it's not great maybe that my background
looks wrong anyway
cannot call 95 that is a simple idea of
this move as a tick check a five
I can take a six as well damn i don't
really believe that is grade
I actually forgot that he can do that
that's not good I was thinking before I
shouldn't take because he gets the porn
but and it's still allowed it
it's still not so easy
Queen d8 maybe and just keeping
everything under control
ok it's got Ruby six if I move the rock
so I have to take or wait what about the
back rank is some background stuff that
I can do fortunately not let's got the
chick mmm there's some counter play if
then i can get here somehow we should
see 84 Queenie ADA
I'm not threatening much Queenie a disk
innova and doesn't do much move
I don't see any trick that you really
outplayed me in this game time morning I
can just push it home I mean I have no
idea whatsoever Yemen no I haven't I
jack not much but something Queen age
I'd made check check check check
check
I want the bishop them and was of course
entirely unnecessary what he allowed him
check check check check and I gonna draw
now I think check check cannot shake
because the queen is shining then check
check check gotta draw check check check
check check grah I'm check check check
check check come on Chandra Wow it was
mega lucky I mean he completely killed
me in this game yeah I was playing at a
very relaxed fashion here like whoo whoo
whoo okay let's be quick but don't care
so much if it is any good but it was it
was kind of okay still I believe him but
yeah of course I mean absolutely never
ever ever ever take on 86 but I just I
just forgot that he can take the depart
I was yeah here I've in huge trouble t
in particular and a five and ten dingu
k6 was even stronger it he's winning
here this is a strategic win and also
tactical when I mean it's comp is on
minus six this is that was strange he
didn't need to do that even though it's
still wins of course check check check
check check
I need a jacket the show I mean he's
still winning but I it's a draw yeah he
had citroën Queen takes e4 still winning
even here or better for black yeah yeah
well I Curie I'll play me in who ok
thanks for watching